ただいま
今帰ってきましたーー
なんか聞いてくださいよなんか東京から俺空で帰ろうと思ったんですけどなんかここは
数点レストが入って
静岡まで行かなかったんですよ
ああ
なんでもう帰れなくて
漫画喫茶にいますた東京にできましたーーー
ほとんどねー
色々ありあるんですよまあおっ会自体もすごい
有意義なものになったんですけどいろんなものが
なんだそれからといろんなことがあったんですよ
オフ会本当に
来てくださった方ありがとうございました
なんかすごい
土を使いっていうだけで宣伝しなかったんですけど
まあ20人近く集まっていただきましたん
すごいなんか色々貰ったんですよ
写し色紙もいただきましたん
本当に入っ
するありがとうございます
新種そうなも不快になるとパンティーズ道
約束しててあの劇団スカッシュさんの
達也さんの監督した行き着くっていう
映画を見てきたんですよこれですね行き着く
なんか本当に
すごい普段作る
敵の練習量の半分の量で
劇をすると言う
ことだったんですけど本当に楽しかったしすごい笑いました
ん
ビギナーズ化し何とも話せでん
楽しかったです本当に
始めたつをって言ってくれたのが嬉しかったです
高校生も
映画製作するの木フィルムのリーダーの鈴健くんとあって
開く総会のあげるともらって
すぐ本当にその深いしに東京に行ったんですけど
なんかすごいいろんな
いろんな方とあえて
じゃあは満足じゃべそノートこんにちはー
今日
県なお店で
ブーバーし
ような事僕も辺の可能性問題のを買いました
2編がわかってへんなの食べるんですがいつですねまぁ全部品ですねうんん
てくれます争奪いいだけじゃなくて
ちょっとにゃん
売ってるねええええええええええええやん
折田こっ
とかそんな苦難化石が離れ離れになっちゃったんですよね
結婚できは離れてるんですよねますけどこれらは心はスーッというわけでアバン
ティーズとこう
解散して
モールさんと帰りましたお疲れさんこれさんはじめじゃないですか
アースジョイこいつだったら2
んだけど
オスカイマー
まあ
まあいきましたね成功ですが成功して tt やつ df
肝臓をスカイの後僕たちはいかないですよね
名古屋に行くんだよ
関西不十分じゃなかった
関東ぷ2犯罪ぷ着のあとアークたちゃいけないですね
名古屋に行くんだよね長いんですよ
待っててください本当に
楽しかったですだけで僕は午後から授業があるんで
大学に行ってきます
本当に東京でお世話になった方ありがとうございましたじゃん
思っ